ينضم الينا مشاهدينا الحاج مدير مكتب
العربيه في نيويورك وايضا من تورنتو رفاه
سعد مراسلات العربيه ومن واشنطن ريتا
سليمان مراسله العربيه سابدا مع زميل طلال
الحاج طلال كيف هي صوره من يعني الوضع سيء
جدا بحسب الصور المباشره التي نتابعها من
هناك وما هي الاجراءات التي تتخذها
السلطات
بالفعل الصوره قادمه اللون الاحمر يسود
على الجو وهذا من يوم امس الثلاثاء في
واقع الامر وسيستمر حتى منتصف الليل على
اقل تقدير وربما استمر ليوم او يومين
اخرين حسب اتجاه الرياح القادمه من كندا
الى الجنوب اذا تغيرت اتجاه الرياح يمكن
ان تخف هذه المشكله في صعوبتها هنا في
نيويورك طبعا السحب دخانيه مكونه من
جزيئات صغيره من الكربون قد يستنشق
الانسان الى رئته وفقا للاطباء تدخل مجلس
دم ويعاني كلبا من اثاريا وخاصه اولئك
الذين يعانون من مرض الربا او الربي او
الازمه ولذلك نصحت الحكومه المحليه وعوده
المدينه صباح اليوم في مؤتمر صحفي بان
يرتدي المواطنون المدينه اقنعت الوجه لمنع
ت الجزيئات ويشاهد الان مناظر تذكرنا بعام
2020 وهم يلبسون لكن على الطبيه الواقيه
كما كان يلبسونها ايام الانتشار
الكوفيد المدارس الثلاثي وقت ما زالت
مفتوحه كما تفضلت في ليال ولكن جميع
النشاطات الخارجيه خارج الفصول تم الغائها
وما زال العمل ساريا في اليوم المتحده
وكذلك في بورصه نيوكلا العالميه على قدم
وثائق ولكن هناك نصيحه لمعظم العاملين
بعدم القدوم للعمل الا للضروره اما مطارات
نيويورك هناك تاخر في الرحلات في مطار
غوارديا وثاني اكبر مطار وكذلك نيويورك
بينما يستمر مطار جي اف كي في العمل بصوره
طبيعيه حتى هذه اللحظه
اثنى عشر ولايه امريكيه حتى الان متاثره
بصحب الدخان بدرجات مختلفه اسواؤها
نيويورك
مليون مواطن في شمال غرب ووسط الولايات
المتحده متاثرين الان بسبب الدخان وكذلك
في الولايات مثل
فرجينيا بنت البانيا وحتى نورمال وفقا
للنحوال الجويه الان
نراقب اتجاهات الرياح من كندا وهي لسوء
الحظ ما زالت الى الجنوب وستستمر غدا
الخميس شكرا لك طلال الحاج مدير مكتب
العربيه حدثنا من نيويورك مشاهدينا سانتقل
الى واشنطن الان وزميلا سليمان
ايضا هل ممكن ان ننقل الصوره من هناك لو
سمحتي
طبعا كما تشاهدين
دعيني اخرج من اطار الكاميرا
الضباب يلف مدينه واشنطن الان
معالم المدينه بدات تختفي تدريجيا
وايضا رائحه الدخان معباه في الهواء لا
نستطيع ان نتنفس بشكل طبيعي وايضا دعيني
اشير بانه حركه السير في المدينه ليست على
طبيعتها في مثل هذا الوقت من
النهار العمل يوم العمل طبعا ايضا
المستشفيات متاهبه للتعامل مع ازمات
التنفس خاصه مع من يعانون من الربو وامراض
القلب
يعني يعني ابلغت الناس بعدم الخروج كلا
حتى الان السلطات لم تمنع المواطنين من
الخروج من منازلهم ولكن من المتوقع ان
تسوء جوده الهواء يوم غد اليوم مؤشر
الهواء نسبه جوده الهواء في واشنطن بلغت
176 هو رقم عال ولكن من المتوقع غدا ان
يرتفع بظل استمرار حاله الطقس واستمرار
الرياح على ما هي عليه
وحدها الرياح يمكن ان تزيح هذه الازمه
دعيني اشير ليال بانه ولايه بنسلفانيا
المجاوره تم اعلان بعض المناطق فيها تحت
المؤشر الاحمر وهو مؤشر خطير جدا تماما
مثل المؤشر في نيويورك ساعود اليك ريتا
اسمحي لي ان انتقل الى رفاهه من كندا
للنقل الصوره رفاه يعني العديد من الحرائق
هناك خرجت عن السيطره حرائقين مسبوقه
وهناك مطالبه لدعم دولي للمساعده باخماد
هذه الحرائق كيف هي الصوره من هناك وهل
ستسوق بالساعات المقبله
بحسب البيئه الكنديه والصحه ايضا قالت ان
هذا الصيف صيف عام 2023 هو الاسوا في
تاريخ كندا من ناحيه ارتفاع درجه الحراره
والجفاف وزياده الحرائق في الغابات
الحرائق مستمره مثل ما تعلمين لذلك
تحذيرات بسبب تلوث البيئه وتلوث الهواء
الذي وصل الى نسبه الخطوره استنشاقه وصل
الى نسبه الخطوره على حياه الاشخاص خاصه
ممن لديهم امراض تنفس امراض القلب طبعا
اليوم وصلت رسائل الكترونيه الى اولياء
امور في مدينه تورنتو وايضا المدن التي
حولها من انه الغيت جميع النشاطات
المدرسيه التي تكون في الخارج ايضا الغي
يوم الركض العالمي الغيت بعض الانشطه
الرياضيه الموجوده في الخارج حضرت السلطات
الناس من عدم الخروج الا للحالات الضروره
طبعا مثلما تشاهدين من خلفي يبدو ان ان
اللون اللي كان الاصفر او الاحمر بدا
قليلا فالشمس تحاول ان تخترق
الغيوم اللي كانت ملبده بالدخان الاسود
اليوم شهد اختلافا قليل مهما كان لكن
التحذيرات من تلوث الهواء لازلت مستمره
نتحدث نعم
اسمحي لي ان اعود الى
تحذيرات من تلوث الهواء اليوم هناك تحذير
لاكثر من 30 مليون امريكا حول موضوع يعني
التلوث الموجود بالهواء وهناك بعض
الولايات التي من المتوقع بساعات الليل ان
تسوء الاوضاع فيها عن اي ولايات نتحدث وما
هي الاجراءات المتخذه حتى الساعه
من المتوقع طبعا ان تزداد
جوده سوءا جوده الهواء سوءا في الولايات
ولايه فرجينيا وولايه ميريلاند طبعا ميري
لاند المتاخمه لبنسلفينيا التي كما ذكرت
سابقا بانه تم اعلان بعض المناطق فيها تحت
مستوى الاحمر ولايه فيرجينيا وايضا
كارولاينا ان كان ولايه كارولينا الشماليه
وحتى كارولينا الجنوبيه هذه المناطق
الواقعه في الشمال الشرقي للولايات
المتحده كلها تقع تحت تاثير هذه الحرائق
وهذا الهواء الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها
حتى اللحظه هي اجراءات طبيعيه حتى اللحظه
مصحه تعبير المدارس هنا مستمره لم يتم
الاعلان عن اي عطل في الغد ولكن تم انهاء
جميع
جميع الدروس والحصص
التعليميه رحلات الخارجيه
نعم بالفعل وصلت قوات متعدده جنسيات خاصه
الى مقاطعه فمثلا فرنسا ارسلت مئه من
قواتها لدعم رجال الاطفاء في كبك وايضا
بالاضافه الى الجيش الكندي طبعا الذي وصل
منذ ايام مثل ما تعلمين ان الحرائق مشتعله
في اكثر من 100 غابه كلها هذه خارجه عن
السيطره هناك الاف النازحين عن هذه
المناطق مثلما تشاهدين خلفي ليال انا
تقصدت اليوم ان اقف في احدى الغابات هذه
الغابات في كندا انها غابات كبيره وفيها
ايضا اشجار ضخمه وكبيره وخشب فعندما يندلع
حريق واحد في واحده من هذه الغابات ينتشر
بسهوله خاصه سرعه الرياح التيار بدات رفاه
سنبقى نتابع نقل الصوره معك مع الزملاء
بالنشرات اللاحقه شكرا لك رفاه السعد
مراسله العربيه من كندا وريتا سليمان
مراسلات العربيه من واشنطن شكرا لكمما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتق ارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات